-Hey, bud!
Oh, it's so good to see ya,
and thank you for doing the
TikTok dance challenge with me.
-I was honored. I was honored.
Thank you.
-I haven't seen you in a while
on the show
because you took a break
from acting.
And you're now a dad.
-Exactly, man. Yeah.
I feel lucky I got to
take some time off,
and I have two boys, and it's --
it's the best, man, the best.
-Look at that.
Look at the smile.
-I know. It's so true.
-It's the greatest thing.
I'm so happy because
you're just a perfect --
I always saw you being a dad,
so I think it's great.
-Thanks, man. That's one of
the sweetest things
you could say about a person.
I saw you in that documentary
about dads
that Bryce Dallas Howard made
about dads,
and I was -- I've been wanting
to tell you this
ever since I saw it.
I saw it a few weeks ago.
And you were --
you were saying like --
The question was
"What is a dad?"
And you were like, "A dad is"
and you were looking for
the right word,
and you were like, "a hero."
And I just about started crying
when you said that, man.
-I was like, "I said that?"
-Thinking about, like,
what you --
I'm someone's dad now, 'cause I
remember looking up to my dad
that exact same way, and just --
-Yeah.
-You know, there's not really
a lot of other people
you can just grab them
and be like, "Ohh."
-[ Laughs ]
-You know what I mean?
-Yeah, exactly right.
And I think there probably
will come a certain age
where it's not that easy to get
them and do that, you know?
-Yeah, you're probably right.
Right now I still can.
-Yeah, I know, me too.
You know, "HitRecord," I always
loved that you created this
before, like, there was any kind
of collab going on the Internet.
It was way ahead of its time,
and I love that you made that,
and I still check it out.
-Dude, you've been a supporter
of it for the whole time.
You were an early,
early champion
of the whole "HitRecord"
community.
-It's created so many awesome,
fun, creative things.
And on the site,
it has some creative prompts
for people to see, and just see
how that can inspire something.
And I thought it would be kind
of fun if maybe you could answer
some of the prompts that we've
gotten from the website
and just see what maybe
your answer would be.
-Yeah, sure, sure.
-These are tricky, by the way.
These are great questions.
You can only bring one album
to a deserted island
and have to listen to it on loop
for the rest of your life.
What are you picking?
-I mean, listen to any album
on loop the rest of your life,
that's hard, but --
-It is tricky.
-It's probably "The Point!"
by Harry Nilsson.
-What?!
-Do you know that record?
-I love -- I was gonna say
"Nilsson Schmilsson,"
Harry Nilsson.
-Are you kidding? Really?
-Really, I swear, and we didn't
talk before this.
But "The Point!" --
"Me and My Arrow."
-Yeah, exactly.
-"Think About Your Troubles."
Alright, this one blew my mind.
I would love to know
your answer.
Look at this photo, please.
What is this astronaut thinking?
-She's got her, like, helmet on,
so she can't breathe
the air anymore.
I'm going dark with this.
She can't breathe the air
anymore.
The air's not healthy to
breathe. She can't go outside.
She's trying to write down
her memoir, and she hates it.
So she's throwing it
on the ground.
-I think this picture was taken
last week and she was like,
"When is the new season of
'Ozark'?"
[ Laughter ]
"Let's go. I need something.
Let's go."
I want to talk about your movie.
I saw it.
We had Jamie Foxx on the show.
It's called "Project Power."
Basically the idea is
there might be a new drug
on the planet or a pill that you
take and you become the most --
you have secret superpowers
for five minutes.
-Mm-hmm, yeah, and you don't
know what you're gonna get.
The pill might give you
something good.
It's different for everybody.
It might give you something bad.
Might kill you.
It's an entertaining premise.
-It's a great premise
for a movie.
And I love Dominique Fishback.
I've never seen her before.
-Yes!
-She was fantastic.
-I'm really happy
you brought her up.
She's my favorite part
of this movie.
And I'm a huge Jamie Foxx fan.
Loved him ever since
"In Living Color," everything.
But Dominique Fishback --
Anybody out there who loves
movies, actors, acting,
just a fan of seeing
an up-and-coming new, brilliant
talent -- Dominique Fishback.
I'm so happy to be
her collaborator, her friend.
She's so good.
-Jamie Foxx --
For me, he can do no wrong.
Both of you guys together.
I'm like --
I heard that he comes --
When he does a movie,
he has entrance music on a set.
-[ Laughs ]
He d-- That's true, actually.
-I've never heard of that.
-He does. I mean, I listen to
music on set a lot too.
It's useful when you're trying
to act and concentrate.
I put in headphones, though.
Jamie doesn't come
with headphones.
Jamie comes to set
with a backpack
with a built-in massive speaker
just bumping his music,
whatever he's playing, and he
plays a wide variety of music.
But it's actually really cool
because he's bringing everybody
into his creative process.
You know what I mean?
Like, instead of being like,
"I'm focused, don't talk to me,"
he's like, "Everybody on
the crew feel this with me."
And it really livens
everybody up.
Jamie is brilliant. I love him.
-I got to get one of those
backpacks, like a boompack.
-I know.
-And just like, yeah.
And just come in --
-He pulls it off really well.
It might play
a little differently on you.
I'm just saying.
Like, I love you, Jimmy.
It might play --
[ Laughs ]
-No, but I'll be walking in,
playing Harry Nilsson,
cranking it up.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Joseph Gordon-Levitt
in "Project Power."
Take a look at this on Netflix.
-On your knees,
hands behind your head.
NOPD.
Ah, I see we have a lady
here as well.
You too, ma'am.
Hands, very good.
Thank you.
Now, how's everybody
doing tonight?
You sure you want to do that,
young man?
You ever taken
one of those before?
You haven't, had you?
I can tell.
Now, I bet you heard it can make
you fast, make you strong.
Make this a fair fight,
even though I got a gun
pointed at your face.
-Just twist it, Tommy.
-But that's only if you happen
to have a good power.
Not everybody does.
Some people take it
and just blow up.
-I don't want to do this
anymore, man.
-Shut up.
-So the question is,
what's your power?
Might be good, might be bad.
Nobody knows.
-Take the pill, Tommy.
-Take it.
Go ahead.
I want to see what happens.
-Joseph Gordon-Levitt,
hopefully we get to see
each other in person soon.
"Project Power" begins streaming
this Friday on Netflix.
Hug that family, buddy.
I love you.
-I will, man. Thank you.
-Great to see you.